what were you wrapped up in at 12 where
you had a gun on you and like did you
were you with older people yeah yeah
everybody was everybody I hung out with
was three to five years older okay
everybody so when I was 12 they was 15
15 17.
so when you get arrested at 12 do your
parents like do they they find out like
what what the charges are and like what
how do they feel about that I mean you
know they mad and [ __ ] but
this
it's like what was you gonna do you're
gonna disown me right you guys gotta
accept it yeah so I mean they tried
different different things try to keep
me in the house trying to move me
certain places right I'm gonna find my
way right back to the neighborhood right
so
it didn't really do anything and then I
ended up living my grandparents and they
older so you know they're not you could
put some [ __ ] yeah smoother yeah
damn
so 12 to 30.
is that what you're on probation for
sure damn I couldn't leave the state you
couldn't leave the state of California
for 18 years I couldn't but I did but I
wasn't supposed to what the [ __ ] for
sure that [ __ ] is wild bro
that's crazy because like I know like
probation obviously is better than being
in jail but at the same time it's like
it's just a nice way to try to keep you
a part of the system it's easy it's easy
to keep you do anything yeah anything we
don't like but make it Justified to all
right well then you didn't break that
law but you violated probation so when
did you like uh finally say okay
enough's enough I got to stop [ __ ]
around I got to put a seat belt on I
gotta get some car insurance I got to
stop [ __ ] you know giving them
excuses I didn't get my license until
just recently not that a few years ago
so wait I was driving years out of the
license just riding dirty riding dirty
see I was the same way for a long time
like uh I would say I probably didn't
have car insurance for like
up until I was like 28. I didn't I ain't
yeah I just never got car insurance I'd
have to get pulled over and they'd give
me the no insurance ticket and then you
have like until your court date to prove
you have insurance and that'd be the
only time I'd get it I get rentals get
them took
go get another rental bike or get it
took buy another car get it took do the
rental cars have your name like flag now
no because you know like I never had it
in my name okay I'll just have somebody
get it from me okay you gotta have
license oh yeah that's true like yeah
how the [ __ ] are you gonna get a rental
car no license
I had license though uh like at 17. but
they took it they took it and I didn't
have it for a long time so how many
different times you go to jail 12 right
throughout your adult like both from 12
to now how many times have you been
incarcerated
I mean juvenile hall I lived in juvenile
like I never like my whole family is
safe when I get it when I come home I'm
on a Home Pass when I go back to Junior
Hall that's like the house yeah because
I I spent my whole teenage years in June
at home he was just in and out in and
out yeah for dumb [ __ ] just anything
right but uh I didn't go to the jail and
I got older too much too much like that
right uh
I just went probably life I mean it's a
lot to a lot of people but not to the
people to me to compare the people I
know right but if I like four or five
times
to the county
but I never I ain't I ain't never been
to the pen though hey that's good yeah I
don't like the juvenile hall [ __ ] kind
of uh it made it easier to to program as
an adult and know what and not to do and
how to do [ __ ] so you would say that
like juvenile hall helped uh helped you
with
a staying out of jail as an adult did it
make you a better Criminal is what
you're saying definitely no no because I
I never was like a criminal I just like
had guns and like I was it was like [ __ ]
that is essential yeah it's crazy
because yeah California they make it so
[ __ ] hard for you to like protect
yourself yeah yeah it's wow it's
different here it is itself they got way
better going and you're in the [ __ ]
capital
when it comes to any type of gang [ __ ]
or anything